boa tarde a todos né
obrigada pela oportunidade né de
participação nesse ted unicamp né
com o tutti disse não eu sou maria
silvia radler sou pesquisadora no centro
de memória da unicamp e eu gostaria de
se situar para quem não conhece
rapidamente que a proposta né do do
centro de memória de um centro de
memória da unicamp ela e já existia no
projeto de universidade é defendido pelo
ex reitor referindo vaz desde o início
da universidade durante os anos 70 não
foi possível implementar a esse centro
né de memória ea partir do final da
década de 70 e começo dos anos 80 pela
atuação do professor andré edifício josé
roberto amaral lapa né e se concretizou
a efetivação do centro de memória assim
em julho de 85 o centro de memória
fundado na na unicamp né
acho importante remarca que ele abriga
um importante conjunto documental né e é
bastante diversificado que composto é
por documentos textuais sejam jornais
revistas panfletos diversos folhetos de
diferentes tipos né a a uma vasta
hemeroteca já existentes no centro de
memória disponível para consulta a
inúmeras coleções fotográficas e
documentos também de natureza sonora e
audiovisual
essa documentação é esse em especial a
documentação textual ela abrange o
período de das décadas finais do século
18 até a atualidade e recobre em
especial a história da cidade de
campinas é ea região naquilo que está
relacionado é pertinente essa história
né
como já foi comentado aqui o centro
se essas três linhas de pesquisa
atualmente né
no meu caso eu o meu projeto de pesquisa
de que vou que vou apresentar aqui é uma
vertente dele ele está articulado a essa
primeira linha de pesquisa ea memória
cidade e educação e educação das
sensibilidades né
bom é um projeto de pesquisa que está em
andamento não está concluído ainda então
de maneira geral o que que eu busco
compreender né
eu busco tanto por relacionar
características gerais da nossa moderna
sociedade contemporânea com as
singularidades né
a singularidade da dinâmica cultural
existente numa determinada localidade
relações entre o geral e o particular
com o local
no caso a cidade de campinas assim nesse
sentido o que eu tenho interesse em
fazer estabelecer relações entre
características culturais tendências
sócio culturais que são prevalecentes na
nossa condição urbana atual que
tendências por exemplo a fragmentação
social espacial né da área urbana
diversas formas de individualismo urbano
a fragilização das relações
interpessoais né as que são tendências
culturais que são prevalecentes então
vou buscar nesse projeto estabelece
relações entre essas tendências e
questões culturais urbanas que estão
emergindo ou se intensificando no
decorrer dos anos 60 da década de 60 e
aí o interesse meu em buscar nesse
período indícios de formas de
sociabilidade e de sensibilidade que de
alguma forma estão assinando dialogando
com a nossa contemporaneidade mais
recente
então nesse sentido o período em torno
dos anos 60 e é particularmente
interessante para pesquisa porque
podemos observar nele
a existência ea tensão entre
temporalidades diferentes né
temporalidade ligada ao ritmo do andar
de bonde pelas ruas da cidade a cidade
que se aprende através dessa forma de
circulação na e atemporalidade mais
ligada aos ritmos velozes do circular de
automóvel pelas cidades é um momento de
transição entre essas diferentes
temporalidades e um momento que a gente
pode dizer que a cidade do automóvel
efetivamente está se consolidando está
sem ponto né e eau e neste processo de
imposição do ritmo do automóvel
nós temos também um processo cultural
significativo de perda e esquecimento de
várias histórias e memórias eu trabalho
né do ponto de vista teórico e
metodológico é fundamentada em reflexões
produzidas pelo filósofo walter benjamin
pelo historiador e do atom thomson inter
key pelo sociólogo jorge sim eu richard
ceni nem o solo americano e também busco
né a inspiração nos trabalhos reflexões
extremamente instigantes desenvolvidas
nos trabalhos historiadores maristela
bresciani e jaciel de seixas entre os
meus objetivos de pesquisa eu destaco em
especial o trabalho com as memórias né
das vivências urbanas né neste período e
análise seja das formas de circulação
existente pela cidade seja a análise das
diferentes mediações né que podemos
observar e aprender mediações que se
colocam nos processos de leitura da
cidade de apreensão de apropriação dessa
cidade né processos que vão compondo né
culturalmente aquilo que eu chamaria de
uma educação urbana das sensibilidades
ao falar de sensibilidade e acho
importante que marcar aqui que eu estou
me referindo às sensibilidades
instituídas culturalmente né através de
processos culturais que se movimentam
constantemente no espaço urbano
portanto trata-se de sensibilidades
localizadas socialmente localizadas
historicamente no caso né da do período
que que em análise na década de 50 e 60
a gente observa um processo intenso de
remodelação e modernização urbana em
campinas um processo que vai desembocar
numa forte descaracterização do espaço
urbano né que resultará né
conseqüentemente em perda de importantes
referenciais de memória
neste processo a marcado
fundamentalmente por uma série de
demolições né demolições de diversos
casarões entorno do largo do rosário na
área central da cidade a igreja do
rosário teatro municipal são demolições
bastante emblemática desse período
bastante polêmicas né e é um processo é
que é marcado pelo puro alargamento de
ruas e abertura de novas avenidas né e
nesse período é a linguagem da
verticalização urbana que está se
impondo e sendo valorizado aqui nessas
imagens
nós temos ali a igreja do rosário né
nos anos 50 logo antes de ser demolida a
gente percebe já o início da
fiscalização da área central né urbana
de campinas ea igreja ela está avançando
no que vai ser a avenida francisco
glicério ela vai ser demolida né
diante da justificativa da necessidade
de alargamento do glicério que vai se
tornar uma das principais artérias do
centro da cidade
aí na foto colorida que é da década que
é de 68 essa foto a gente observa né o
vazio deixado pela demolição da igreja
na área central já toda ela circo
dada pelos edifícios que estão se
implantando exatamente nesse período na
cidade né
da mesma maneira o teatro municipal se
localizava atrás da igreja da catedral
metropolitana de campinas
ele vai ser demolido em 65 e na foto
abaixo aqui a gente pode observar o que
sobrou dos escombros do teatro
ali né da os escombros da demolição
eu acho que é interessante ressaltar que
teresina não tão interessante assim mas
o teatro é demolido e durante um bom
tempo fica um é feito um estacionamento
de automóveis ali atrás da catedral e
depois estacionamento vai dar lugar à
construção de uma loja de departamentos
c&a que até hoje está ali no local
portanto esse período ele vai promover
um processo de redefinição das relações
sociais de redefinição da relação das
pessoas com os diferentes lugares da
cidade e registros fotográficos que
observamos nesse período que podemos que
porque eu pude fazer a pesquisa conep
por meio deles são registros tanto de
perdas quanto registros de celebração de
admiração pelo processo de modernização
acelerada que está acontecendo uma
coleção fotográfica muito interessante
que eu analisei foi produzida é por um
fotógrafo amador o josé gomes guarnieri
era um engenheiro que aos finais de
semana saía pela cidade fotografando
aquilo que lhe chamava atenção em um dos
elementos modernos do espaço urbano que
estavam sendo colocados por essa teoria
por essa remodelação né olhar dele é
claramente um olhar de envolvimento com
essa modernização nessa fotografia a
gente vê ali essa
esse círculo em forma de elipse né eles
é o viaduto que está sendo construído
miguel melhado miguel vicente cury na é
colocado numa das entradas da cidade e
ele pretende
ginés e um é um projeto de
redistribuição do tráfego né
a gente percebe ali várias avenidas que
sai do chão sai do viaduto e ele é
considerado na época e muito
propagandeado como sendo expressão das
mais modernas técnicas de engenharia do
período né
no caso desse fotógrafo eles são
inúmeras fotografias do processo desde
construção como a inauguração do viaduto
e ele está sempre apontando para aquilo
que ele chama a atenção e temos dos
detalhes técnicos dessa construção
é quando ele fotografa as ruas da cidade
é um movimento que ele está fotografando
nesta são os carros né o lajeado pelos
edifícios altos então é vamos é um olhar
sensível à a movimentação a idéia de
velocidade
a idéia de progresso técnico né e quando
ele fotografa os edifícios novos né de
arquitetura moderna que estão sendo
construídos ele o enquadramento
fotográfico dele é exatamente apenas o
edifício não impor no né
ou seja a gente poderia dizer que é o
encantamento com relação à a a todo esse
aparato e moderno esses equipamentos
urbanos modernos que estão sendo
constantemente o pai propagandeados
pelos jornais locais e no caso da
imprensa no local eu acho que é
interessante dizer que os jornais locais
nem em sua circulação diária cotidiana
eles estão constantemente trazendo
representações sobre a cidade no sentido
de uma cidade que se sente moderna que
quer ser moderna e que se coloca né se
considera em constante progresso então
cotidianamente essas imagens essas
representações são veiculadas
daí eu chamo atenção pra ir
isso no sentido de que a gente pode
observar um processo cultural que está
em curso de educação do olhar né de
conformação de uma determinada forma de
leitura de percepção da cidade
as matérias jornalísticas ou vão
oferecendo critérios de percepção do que
está ocorrendo aí tá essa imagem é uma
imagem recorrente que aparece aí trago
aí como exemplo temos aí o jardim 15 que
foi feito no interior do viaduto miguel
vicente cury e que é colocado no período
como um belo cartão postal da cidade né
é o jardim chamado lago dos cisnes né e
que vejo ali campinas é isto a legenda
né é um crescendo e irreversível de
progresso esta colocação essa celebração
do que eles do que se entende para o
progresso técnico né
na época mas cara né e dilui as mazelas
sociais de que a cidade é portadora os
problemas sociais existentes nas
contradições as tensões né e vai
apagando a presença de diversos outros
sujeitos que existe na história da
cidade
então concluindo o que eu pretendo
mostrar nessa parte da pesquisa é que
todo esse processo né de entrelaçamento
de com a imprensa as fotografias
produzidas seja as oficiais sejam
amadores vão criando condições para a
emergência de uma forma de sensibilidade
urbana que é mais articulada
o movimento ao andar apressado a atitude
defensiva diante de supostos perigos das
ruas há uma sensibilidade que é muito
mais afeita a valorização do novo
principalmente da novidade uma
sensibilidade que no momento ele não
guarda espaço para discussões sobre
preservação diversidade
memória cultural ou seja são formas de
sensibilidade urbana que eu acredito
poder dizer que dialogam né no tempo com
sensibilidades urbanas com as quais
convivemos hoje estamos imersos nelas
principalmente as relativas ao
individualismo urbano as diferentes
formas de intolerância nas relações
sociais com que temos nos defrontado né
ou seja eu o que eu pretendo mostrar
aqui é a importância de se perceber um
determinado momento da história da
cidade né e que não é apenas a história
desta cidade mas é alguma geral né que
está emergindo formas urbanas de estar
na cidade que encontramos na
contemporaneidade mais recente mesmo tá
muito obrigada pela atenção de vocês